yes men have a part to play but I just
think it's more on the women because we
have control we are in control of birth
if you if you get pregnant you can get
an abortion men have no say in that so
until that's equal I can't say we're in
equally at fault
I think in terms of evolution and we
have 41 forms of birth control what men
have won and we're also in control of
the people that we sleep with you can
require they wear a condom well that's
even misogynistic not develop no no not
developing a lot of birth control for
men when men are having no trouble
that's misogynistic they've tried but it
led to a lot of men being sterilized so
it's it's not massaging there's a new
one they're working on that that's it's
that's just a simple biological equation
because men produce millions of sperm
every day women produce one egg per
month it's easier to control one egg
than it is millions and millions of
sperms so that's just a biological
function that's why it's like that way
it's not because you know scientists are
mean and misogynistic and want to kind
of put it all on women it's just that
it's it's easier that way it's kind of
this you know you just got a barrier you
can just have a barrier
um but it's just a tough thing to work
out also yeah when it comes to women we
know we know the days that
we can get pregnant we can be a little
bit more risque with it and be like okay
I may not have to take the pill of the
day I may not have to go get a plan B we
know when the peak time for us to get
pregnant that's why I think it'd be more
so on the women than the men I'm not
giving awful I'm gonna I'm gonna be
maybe maybe I'm just gonna be like old
school here but look we all we all know
how babies are made man woman we we all
know how this process works
um number one I you know some people
won't like me saying this but I don't
think you should be having sex with
people who you're mortified with the
concept of having a child with exactly
exactly right like if the thought of
having a child with that person is going
to be like the end the end of the world
or some or then maybe you shouldn't be
and this goes for I'm saying this for
men too all right I'm saying this for
men too if the thought of that woman
getting pregnant by you is makes you
want to run to the hills maybe bro you
should you know be be careful there
um so you know these conversations
sometimes frustrate me because it's like
foreign
it's kind of you know it's like look
let's just let's just be mature be
mature about it and make good decisions
and don't be don't be Reckless we have
all there's different options out there
um
everyone knows anyone who knows me knows
I'm straight up pro-life I don't think
that executing the baby is the uh is is
the way forward at all morally
um but there are many things you can do
to prevent that and not get to that
stage
um so I think I think I think I don't
want to let men off the hook on this at
all because
we both both sexes need to just be
responsible and sensible with this like
sex is not I know that modern society
wants to push out and indoctrinate
everyone with this message that it's
just you know some completely random
inconsequential fun activity like Ping
Pong or going to the you know or
whatever but it's like it's got very
serious potential lifelong ramifications
um and it's how we all got here right
it's like it's a it's a major thing and
with something that's that has can have
such potential ramifications you know
people should not treat it so carelessly
I think that's the truth of it it
shouldn't be treated so carelessly and
recklessly and I think if you know and
and by the way people always knew this
like this isn't something new I'm not
saying something new here people knew
this forever which is why there were
certain behaviors that were frowned upon
or promoted and so on and so forth it's
not just trying to be mean to everyone
or to cramp crap cramp down on their
Liberty
um it's like well children are up the
product of this yeah so I just think
that
birth control should be banned oh wow
you should be taken off the market I
agree okay
if I told you that my stepdad had had 14
children yeah what did you think about
that if I say my old stepdad he's my
late stepdad had 14 children
now I said to my son's dad had 16. and
my late step dad
at 14. interesting
the only difference is he had 13 from
one woman okay
but the and the only reason why it's
able to progress like that I believe
because of birth control
can I ask what you guys mean by that by
saying you think birth control like and
I just know women
so basically she's saying that a woman
should not be able to decide to
terminate a child
oh I see I didn't say that
controls
some traditional Catholics oh some
traditional Catholics and they'll tell
you about birth control you want to get
pregnant you have sex otherwise you know
when you're when you're ovulating and
you work around it because proper
Catholics don't believe in child con and
birth control yeah oh I see and um my
sons my my late stepdad
his former partner was Catholic they
have 13 children so every time they were
going to have sex they knew that if we
have it at this time or there's a
possibility because they in those days I
didn't know about ovulating you're going
to get pregnant so if every woman and
every man went out there especially the
women because they're the ones that have
to carry the baby if you knew that every
time you had sex there's a possibility
you got pregnant they be left six why
would I sound as an atheist he doesn't
want kids
as an atheist you don't want kids I just
can't have sex or just have to work
around what I'm going to be ovulating
yes if I have no more periods that be
well you can just work your way around
it
[Music]
also because I am pro-life and I don't
want that would just lead to it that
would lead to a massive spike in
abortions and I think that would be okay
there's more abortions
are there more abortions after the
development of birth control than before
I think we're talking about things in an
Ideal World I think we're forgetting on
this self-determination you can say to
someone you shouldn't do that that is
naive as well I just say as a parent
you're going don't go out and do drugs
and have sex they're going to do it
anyway and that's what we're like a
society we're gonna go out and have sex
we're going to do it with you the
difference is with birth control you
take away the consequence and I just
think there's ramifications when you
take away the consequence if you look at
after the development of birth control
like the chart
um of when birth control was introduced
and then the divorce rate in society
it's like literally the same if we take
away birth control wouldn't what would
happen to the abortion rates exactly I
think women would be I think women would
just be more careful with who they slept
with but that's that's the pressure on
the women
you don't okay
okay
okay
okay
you don't you don't you don't think it's
good that women should be careful with
who we sleep with yes
right right so because you said it's too
much pressure it's too much pressure to
like oh my gosh like I can't feel like
yeah
and stop being pregnant
guys can we understand that women get
horny exactly are you guys are okay with
that concept you know like I am horny
outside of my ovulation piece
these women women
were getting horny before birth control
so you shouldn't have sex no no no no no
I'm saying ovulations I think it goes
back to what zooby said to not sleep
with someone where it's horrible if you
have a child with them of course
exactly so right so you said it's too
much pressure like people used to get
like pregnant back in the day before
birth control they just have a shotgun
wedding and figure it out yeah because
it wasn't the end of it the problem is
that that that that that cow that cat is
out the bag now
right so in the past in a much more
traditional and a much more religious
Society
the answer to a you know
premarital pregnancy simple answer get
married and that's still that's still a
good answer for a lot of people as far
as I'm concerned however with the way
that marriage has changed there have
been too many changes to then go and go
okay let's ban birth control now and
you've already let all these other cats
out the back to me that's just that's
just chaos I just want to see what
happens I I feel like girls would make
better decisions if there was a
consequence I don't I think you just get
a huge spike in abortions yeah I don't
think you'd get a gigantic Spike no no
we should ban that too let's ban both
okay then that's different as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible